a new report from the International
Rhino foundation found three of the
world's five Rhino species could be lost
within our lifetime perhaps no species
is closer to extinction than the
northern white rhino there are only two
left in the world
scientists at the San Diego Zoo Safari
Park are part of an international effort
trying to save the species John
Blackstone looks at their latest
accomplishments this southern white
rhino named Victoria is pregnant oh
she's moving quite a bit at 17 weeks her
calf is about the size of a small banana
feet down here spine here there's her
head that bright spot with her head you
see the movement it's a big moment for
Barbara Durant director of reproductive
sciences at the San Diego Zoo this
pregnancy is really significant for us
because it was a result of artificial
insemination and the sperm we use was
frozen so that's a big hurdle there have
only been a few Rhino births from
artificial insemination Victoria is one
of six southern rhinos taking part in a
study of their complex reproductive
system a study to help save from
extinction another branch of the white
rhino family northern white rhinos open
we want Victoria to carry this pregnancy
to term the reason that it's important
for us and for all the other females
that surround a rescue center is that
they eventually are going to be
surrogates or embryo transfer recipients
for northern white rhino embryos the
northern white rhino was on the verge of
vanishing forever in 2015 at the San
Diego Zoo Safari Park
we met NOLA and elderly northern white
one of just five left on the planet she
likes to be rubbed behind her ear that
behind her ear NOLA has since died all
five species of rhinos face the same
threat demand on the black market for
their horns mistakenly believed to have
medicinal properties in 2017 poachers
killed more than eleven hundred rhinos
today only two northern White's remain a
mother and a daughter in Kenya under
24-hour armed guard
they were poached to extinction we feel
it
our responsibility to bring that species
back Victoria and five other southern
whites were relocated to San Diego from
South Africa this one arrived with a
wound in her side they brought the bomb
squad out to come and x-ray her because
our x-ray equipment can't shoot through
a rhino they're just too big they
confirm for us that there were fragments
of bullets inside of her the hope is
that these southern white females will
become surrogate mothers for northern
white embryos but creating those embryos
depends largely on the safari parks
frozen zoo the largest gene Bank in the
world with samples from some 10,000
animals so we have cell lines from 12
different northern white rhinos and that
is enough genetic diversity to bring
back a self-sustaining population of
northern white rhinos Durant believes
assisted reproduction and stem cell
research gives scientists an opportunity
to resurrect the northern whites
a team from the Leibniz Institute in
Berlin has been perfecting a procedure
to harvest rhino eggs and hopes to
extract eggs from the remaining two
northern white females this fall
not so long ago the population of
southern white rhinos was also drinking
breeding programs have helped their
survival
Durant hopes one day perhaps years from
now a newborn northern white will bring
the promise of a return from extinction
it's a very emotional thing for us to
see a species become extinct before our
very eyes but we have those cells safe
in the frozen zoo so it gives us hope
for CBS this morning John Blackstone
Escondido California what an amazing job
that scientists can do I wish them a lot
of luck and so encouraging I have my
six-year-old I hope he's watching this
is something he was really into when you
find out they're only two so this is
good news hope you're watching Jake